bientôt c'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur there is no game je
vous mets conseiller en masse notamment
juste pour toi papa pape
pas ce qui va se passer vous avez
surtout trop les voilà c'est un joueur
français du coup on m'avait dit voilà
comme ça pour une fois tu t'en sortiras
mais je vous bête ces partis alors
apparemment le but du jeu c'est qu'il ya
pas de jeu voilà pas un jeu de karaoké
d'accord avec qui il va apprendre le des
liens probablement pas fait avec
construction c'est drôle at elle jugé
there is no games baba
à la voix est en anglais mais s'est créé
à l'écran donc je vous laisse lire
impulse en fait il n'y a pas de jeu
j'espère vous n'êtes pas trop déçu de
pas vu le nom du jeune houtekiet pas de
jeu en fait après vous pouvez toujours
regarder la télé sortir art est
allé à toi un truc aller se dégage ça
dégage tu es toi voilà voilà génial
comme idée vous venez de ruiner le titre
je te baise remettez la remettez la
lettre commandes tiger est tu peux pas
d'ordre hockey non mais oh bah je suis
pas là mais saches pas mon gars je ne
peux pas la remettent ça ne marche pas
et si jamais la tereos end game ou alors
series ou alors on arrête cette blague
là ça va regarder un petit truc qui
tombe de là où avait évoqué dès que ça
descend ça fait tomber le truc allez on
t'a mur l'a vu clair dans son jeu mon
gars tu es foutu ça des garrots le on va
voir le but et c'est sûr
c'était c'était horrible je sais on a
des choses horribles genevois vous savez
ouais et noir sans voix c'est comme
la mort un noise hausse en elle une
salle de bar soins cabine de douche un
squeeze sur une coupe de merde du coup
faire quoi à moi le moi je vais être
gentil je veux pas faire on le fait
chier apparemment on veut juste d'être
gentil à faut mettre ça pour casser ça
voilà je pense vraiment a trop de trucs
on essaie de le tuer ok j'ai compris
au maire daley je vais attendre larmes
sincères club qui serait pas juste à
temps dans un endroit à cliquer
nom âge est à moi allez ça suffit
maintenant tu vas faire quoi au hasard
il a mis en garde aussi alors désolé je
n'aime pas il est ce genre de procédure
mais je n'ai pas le choix l'homme était
un barbare y'a pas il ya aucun problème
est là on va péter la truck voilà voyez
bon gérer vue dans l'avenir on le
supplément des superman pour celle là
la gamme et la kryptonite bonjour tu ne
sais pas qui je suis jeune robot je suis
super man
en tout cas c'est super marrant comme
principe d'interagir avec ce mec base
aux salles péter je pense tu fais ça ah
non vraiment pas à bavois
wassakara que je casse à malte le non
jeu mais oui alesi maîtriser ma vie à
bord calme toi j'espère que vous aller
nettoyer avant de partir mais même moi
c'est toi qui avais une plaque de titans
qui fait d'automne aussi faut cliquer
sur ça c'est davis avec la visseuse
bosch on peut on se souviendra je
dévisse le jeu [ __ ] c'est qu'on abat
alors il parait qu'il ya pas de jeu ben
hassine garde mon gars il y a un jeu de
notre attaque faire exploser le pow wow
sortez d'ici non mais voilà on a trouvé
un jeu donc si vous jouez ils vont venir
qui qui qui qui qui guide ses chiens
d'un grand mère sans blague allez on
joue ces parties arrêtez de donner les
briques
c'est quoi ce délire je vais trouver un
moyen de vous arrêter mais tu pourras
pas ont gardé trop malin un génie des
noms oui peut-être alors qu'aucune balle
nulle part bah si on a une la regarde
hop là voilà j'en étais sûr allez je ne
me sens pas bien mais arrête on a trouvé
ce que tu caches et c'est tout il se
veut un style il dit qu il y dit que
c'est pas un jeu alors que c'est un jeu
ben voilà c'est quelqu'un de faux
oula oula oula au [ __ ] on a touché un
organe vital ils sont là les bugs
c'est génial tâche avec windows dans
l'habitude au bugue bill gates vous et
moi un moyen de nous sortir de là c'est
un désastre on fait quoi comment je vais
venir un succès commercial avec tous ces
bugs mois maintenant qu'est-ce qu'un
développeur ajouterait pour prendre une
création tout bogey je vois trois
possibilités des superman et armés
jusqu'aux dents s'étonne le zombie ou
bien une
chèvre je sais pas comment et s'est
trouvé l'une de ces trois choses ok on y
va c'est parti
avec la coupe on fait quoi elles sont
les lettres there is there is the gold
voilà là on n'a pas de 1,6 hong hao
alors ça va faire paraître une chef
c'est ça oui coûte c'est génial comme je
sais en génial voilà qu'elle est
verrouillé vous ai trouvé la clé l'on a
bien là l'écureuil voulons la prise vous
devez la récupérer ça n'a aucun sens il
faut trouver quelque chose pour bonté
pour grimper ça me rappelle mon enfance
jusqu'à est un immense arbre dans le
dans le jardin pour récupérer je sais
pas quoi oui j'ai eu une enfance à
madame et regardez on va mettre toutes
les lettres comme ça non je cherche une
échelle ta gueule et bien social vous
êtes coincé non peut-être que vous ne
parlez pas d'utiliser vous cliquer
partout à la toile - depuis le début non
il nous a grillé [ __ ] lui trêve alors
bon allez oust l'échelle arabe
l'espagnol c'est dans les classes
bon allez peut-être le français oui je
parle français
à oui à toi fais un arbre [ __ ] autant
pour moi voilà ce que je parle très bien
anglais finalement on peut le dire hu
est au mouillage simplement quand même
de l'engrais allons tout de l'engrais
pour qu'on utilise les besoins de la
chèvre en engrais comment vais grandir
cet arbre en lui tapant dessus avec la
coupe
vous avez vu c'est exactement ce à quoi
on s'attendait there is game of thrones
here is more mon frère était mort mais
comment on fait pousser cet arbre a
bloqué alors [ __ ] j'y crois que ça
fait grandir la coupe je suis peut-être
un peu pompette à la seule coupe que
j'ai vu cette veille d'une coupe de
champagne
moyens je demande ça sans vous je te
prendrais l'énarchie comme comme un
élastique qui comme un moustique un pic
ont un ou deux clics l'âge lastic nous
faut peut-être un stylo bic en tout cas
cet avis n'est pas sympathique qui vous
n'êtes pas content eh ben je vous dis je
suis super lourd alors comment on fait
pousser cet arbre à la fin
aux as et regarder la cheville de
couleur ok pour la remplir d'eau à aller
grandi douala pouce vient te plaît allez
grandir on dit voilà on peut monter la
maman salut jeunes écureuils qui cassent
bière et steak
je vais le faire exploser sa pas marché
alors comment je prends la clé il faut à
la et un petit gland et avait commis les
cons qui aurait pu avoir lieu à l'égard
des lacs et en plus et simard avec je
défonce la clé bois assez bien je
sortais mongolie
noms la cheffe d'état mensongèrement ses
parents je suis quoi c'est de pire en
pire mais excuse moi j'appuie ce que tu
m'as dit encore plus de bugs je me noie
au revoir
aux jeux au choix qui était mort je ne
suis pas mort je suis vivant du jeu puis
a disparu à part moi c'est quoi le
délire là moment confession je vous ai
mis en danger c'est entièrement ma faute
s'il vous plaît vous me pardonnez
pardonner de nous avoir entraîné dans
cette histoire il faut des larmes je
suis triste ne s'est pas tu as trop
jouer au con carlos sais pas si on peut
pardonner tu as vraiment fun à ouaga
alors je t'aime je te pardonne but
vraiment quelle bonne nouvelle je sais
qu'un peut-être pour devenir ami
peut-être 15 non non c'était pas une
bonne idée houngbo va-vite seriez tous
les deux mais non mais pourquoi parce
que comme je le dis il n'y a pas de jeu
oui bah voila j'ai enseigné repas 100
bio science des risques hogan n'hésitez
pas à aller mais ça vous a plu ben
écoute et merci d'avoir conseillé ce jeu
parce que enfin ce nom jeu parce que il
était en français doit s'en fout non
sens et j'ai trouvé ça super original et
bien foutu c'était hyper cool et en plus
tu es en france et donc celui à très
bientôt au tchad mondes bis
[Musique]